a stone sculpture of Egypt's famous King
Tut is at the center of an international
dispute this morning the bust of the
revered boy King is set to be auctioned
off later today in London for an
expected five million dollars but
Egypt's government says the artifact was
stolen and wants the sale stopped
Charlie d'Agata is inside London's
Petrie Museum of Egyptian archaeology
charlie good morning good morning
Egyptian antiquities like these are on
display in museums like this all around
the world but King Tut holds a special
place so when his head showed up on the
auction block at Christie's the
controversy kicked off he is the most
famous Pharaoh in the world and that
face unmistakable the features the eyes
the cheekbones and the lips are
immediately recognizable as eternally
young his soft features captured in hard
stone in the sculpture thought to be
more than three thousand years old and
Egypt believes it's time for King
Tutankhamun to come home that the bust
is stolen merchandise and it's not
ancient history
we spoke with former Egyptian
antiquities Minister Zahi Hawass I
really believe that Christy should have
some ethics this is a head of a famous
King that Egypt and the whole world
would love how can you put a head of
that King to be on sale and they never
tell us about the origin about how they
bought it from Egypt whose ownership of
this piece the bust might have remained
locked inside King Tut's tomb forever
had the to not have been discovered
intact with all its treasures in the
1920s by British archaeologist Howard
Carter Christie's contends that the bust
has been under rightful ownership of a
private collection in Germany since 1985
after passing through several hands
since the 1960s how it found its way to
Europe is still something of a mystery
justice is at the forefront
for the protection of circle object this
piece has been widely published and
exhibited is a very well-known piece so
there hasn't been any claim on the piece
and we haven't received any evidence
from the Egyptian authorities about the
problem but Egyptian authorities insist
it was looted and Christie's has failed
to prove otherwise
and we will fight until the head of the
Ponca moon our great famous King should
come back the real truth may never be
known
a mystery locked forever somewhere
behind the gentle eyes of Egypt's boy
king now cairo is so upset with this
cell that the ambassador here has filed
a complaint we contacted the relevant
government office who told us we expect
any sale to be in accordance with the
law and this is a matter for Christie's
Jericka Charlie d'Agata thank you for
that